all right cat yes
cat where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um Southgate Michigan
also known as the lake down river that's
what we called it south of Detroit yeah
tell me about your family growing up
um my mom was a single mom I have a
sister
um I have a sister that passed away when
my mom was pregnant with me and my mom
was in a domestic violence situation
with my dad she ended up leaving him
when he got another woman pregnant and I
lived with her primarily after that she
got married a few times and like we
moved around a lot
and there wasn't a lot of stability
and I never really clicked with my
stepdads in any capacity so I think from
a very young age I was always seeking
like male affection
um like my first kiss was super young I
think it was like eight or something and
then I had sex at like 11. for the first
time
um with like a boyfriend it was like a
healthy experience as healthy as it can
get for 11.
um but my mom wasn't home often and
she'd sent me to live with my aunt and
uncle for a while because they had like
a traditional nuclear family so she
thought I would be better off with them
because they had money and like
stability so she thought
and then my cousin got pregnant at 15.
and they kind of like told me I had to
leave because like I was the reason all
the guys were coming around and
they wanted me to like go back to my mom
so I went back to her and that's kind of
when [ __ ] hit the fan
she was never home so I went from having
like all these extracurricular
activities like I was showing horses and
like doing all these things and back
home there was nothing like I was just
by myself a lot
um I'm super emotional and affectionate
so
again I like really needed I needed like
feedback emotional feedback
so I sought that out I started running
away to Southwest Detroit
and then ended up dropping out of
traditional high school and going to
Alternative High School which got the
ball rolling even more because the whole
like the whole group of kids at that
school was all they were all doing like
bad stuff so I started out in Southwest
Detroit hanging out with this family
that was extremely dysfunctional and
that's when I started like trying drugs
and I went to like this house
this guy named Tino he was like a Latin
count or something like a gang banger
and we walked in and there was like
cocaine from the floor to the ceiling
like bundles like filled his entire
house
that was the first time I tried cocaine
and then I like wasn't into like that
like
Vibe I guess like Mexican I was always
attracted to black guys so
I ended up going further out into the
city like the west side
and running away there by myself like
just got on a bus
and went down there and ended up meeting
this girl her name was Veronica I don't
know if that's her real name but she
um kind of like took me under her wing
and was really nice
and let me stay with her and her
boyfriend Apollo
and it was a weird situation uh so we
like all slept in the same bed but
nothing ever like happened
and she me and her would like walk
around and I remember like that's kind
of when I got the first taste of like
Detroit
like dudes would like drive by and like
try to holler at you and you would
decline and they would like spray you
with water bottle like water guns filled
with piss
so that was a thing
um that happened more than once
um and I made friends with like all
these people that I thought were cool
and like we'd sit and smoke and talk and
like there's like Belle Isle in Detroit
which is like super popular at the time
like all the parks in the summer time
like you just go there like with groups
of people and drink and like they play
music and everybody has their like cars
all like
so yeah
um we did that for a while and then
that's kind of when things shifted
um
I was told like oh this guy James is
looking for you he really wants to talk
to you and was like okay like who is it
and he I was at this Coney Island on
Grand River and I remember him walking
in he looked really nice very like
Smooth walk I know it's like weird to
say but he wasn't walking like somebody
that I would like because I knew how to
like identify men that were more
aggressive just by their like energy and
he didn't have that energy at all so he
offered to
buy me chili fries
and he bought my chili fries
and I ate them and he was nice so he was
like you can come stay with me like I'll
help you get on your feet and take care
of you like I have a few other girls
that are staying with me and you know
you guys would get along really well and
I was just like okay like I had no idea
that there was like even like pimp
culture that's how like far removed I
was
so he took me there and then he was like
I walked in and there were sure like
girls sitting in the living room doing
their makeup like chit chatting like
they were like friends
and I was just like oh this is cool like
why are they all white that's like the
first thing
and they're all young they were always
14 at the time
so I'm like they were all pretty close
in age
and
um they didn't say anything bad about
him they didn't warn me there was no
like
this is what this is it was just sort of
like I got eased into it and he like
bought me clothes
and he bought me food and then the day
things like change with him
um I was wearing this like denim jumper
it was like shorts with like buttons
down the front like you couldn't take
the shorts off without unbutting the
whole thing
and
I was like going up these stairs and
that's he like stopped me on the stairs
he was like well I have to like like I
have to test you out before you start
like paying me back for everything that
I bought you
and I was like what do you mean he was
like I just bought you all these clothes
like I bought you makeup like what do
you think I'm just gonna do that for you
for free like you're not going to pay me
back
and I was just like
um like
don't know what to say like I'm sorry
I'll give it back like and that's the
like the switch flipped for him like his
eyes like changed and his eyebrows like
did this thing whenever he got like
serious or you knew that it was like
gonna be an issue
um and he like that's the first time he
like sexually assaulted me was on the
stairs
so
after that
definitely felt a little different about
the situation
um he started like that's when I started
like going like they would always leave
and I didn't know where they went but he
would take groups of girls to different
hotels in the area like we would go to
Knights Inn there was a Motel 6 a Red
Roof Inn on like Telegraph Road I
remember like all of them I remember all
the lobbies
and he would drive us to these hotels we
would all stay in one room together
and it was it was weird it was like
almost like a sorority
because like we were all like stuck in
this situation together and we tried to
like have fun and make the most of it
when he wasn't around if that makes
sense
and there was this girl like that was
with us her name was Treasure and she
like watched the group
she was his baby's mom so she would
bring their son and he would like go
with his dad and like see everything
that was going on like everything
and I was just like what the [ __ ] like
what is going on what do I do and then I
start empathizing with his kid and I
start empathizing with his baby's mom
and I'm almost like that's kind of where
I learned that I have like this pretty
severe savior complex
um I didn't want to leave because I
didn't want to leave him I didn't want
to like like abandon the situation if
that makes sense so it kind of like
pulls you in and like
makes you feel like you're a part of a
family but in this like really [ __ ] up
way so
oh there is can't leave you can't leave
the first time I knew that I was it was
a Red Roof Inn on Telegraph Road
and I walked down into the lobby walked
outside I think I was going to the
vending machine or something and I just
walked outside because I was like I've
been in a hotel room for two days like I
just want to go outside
I went outside and there was this family
this like family that kind of reminded
me of my family and I like started
talking to the dad he was just talking
making small talk with me
and I didn't say anything wrong I just
was like trying to feel like normal for
a second and I remember walking back
into the room and this girl
I don't want to say her name
but she she was the one that was like
always with me and she's the one I wish
I knew where she was but she
um was in the in there on the bed
and I walked in and I'm like looking at
her not paying attention and the door
shuts behind me and he pops out from
behind the door and like socks me in the
side of my face like right side of my
face
and I hit the floor and she's just
sitting there like holding her face
and I was like
didn't know why like I didn't know what
I did he was like don't ever [ __ ]
talk to anybody again
like and he walked out that was it end
of the conversation and I was like
terrified like I'd never been hit by a
guy before
like and not expecting it I couldn't
brace for it I couldn't like Dodge it it
just like cold hit me in the side of my
face
um so that was enough for me to like
I'm like okay I'm good like I don't know
what else he can do I'd seen him like
rape other girls you know with us like
he would do it in the room
two of us would usually share a room if
there was like an in-call one of us
would step out and go into like the
group room
so it was like a whole like system that
we had
and
I've never talked about like
like any of the times that I've like had
to like work
I've always dodged that topic because
it's hard to talk about
um
but I do remember that year the Red
Wings won the Stanley Cup
so I don't know what year that was I
just remember like everybody was outside
like screaming
and that was like I was in a hotel room
and there were two men in the hotel room
and me and this other girl she was
younger than me I think she must have
been like 13. she was from like Indiana
or something
and
these guys came in and I swear I was
like they look just like my uncle like
just like normal white dudes wearing
like Dockers and like
boat shoes like corny like I don't I
don't know how to explain it I was just
like what and they had wedding rings on
and I remember feeling so like it just
like I just want to go home so bad
because I knew like I was gonna have to
like do stuff with them
and um
sorry I never talk about this
um
I'm gonna have mascara all over my face
like it's so funny I skirt it and I like
I'm like oh yeah like I was sex
trafficked and I like try to bring
awareness to it but I'm always like
I always kind of like hid that that part
like that I actually had to like work
I never like had to stand on the street
like I wasn't like a street prostitute
and I'm sure it was because like I was
underage like he would get in a lot of
trouble if it was me you know or like
any of those girls
and um maybe I just didn't feel like I
like was doing the same type like I was
like oh well I wasn't I wasn't like
Street walking like I was in a room or
like but he would take us to their house
um
but yeah uh doing that like that was
hard that night was really hard
and um there was a time I had this like
bleeding disorder this hormonal like
bleeding Disorder so when I was like 12
I think
I had to like have blood transfusions
because I was on this birth control pill
that made me like clots and I like
almost bled to death
so I'd have a blood transfusion and I
had to be on this specific birth control
to like stop the bleeding
for that like time
and I ran out of it at 12. yeah you have
birth control yeah yeah because they had
started having sex at 11. my whole
family has teen moms so I think my mom
was just trying to like not let me get
pregnant but it didn't work anyway
um
so anyway I ran out of my pill and I and
I couldn't work because I was bleeding
like all the time
and he was like getting angry with me
because I couldn't do anything except
like give a [ __ ]
and that wasn't like you don't get paid
enough for that he's I'm not making him
money it's not worth the gas to like go
do that
so he ended up like apparently he knew a
doctor
because he took me to this room and he
was like we're going to get your
prescription he's like all you have to
do is like trick this guy
and you'll he'll give you a prescription
when you're done
and I was like
what do you mean so I like walk in the
room not knowing it was this Asian guy
he was like he looked like a doctor he
looked like a nerd
and I was like
like what the [ __ ] I ended up like
having to like have full-blown like sex
with him and he handed me a script after
for my for my birth control
and I was like oh my God like
it's almost like a feeling of like
complete hopelessness because you like
all these men that you're like meeting
and you're doing these things with
you're like 14 you're under age 90 of
them have on wedding rings
there's a doctor
and you're just like who doesn't do this
like who doesn't like
look at me in this way or like girls in
this way or young girls or whatever and
it's like no matter where you go it's
like the same thing like I
I felt almost like even like if I
stepped out or if I went home like it's
the same thing I'd always been
sexualized from a very young age like
men like cat calling or whatever like
before I even had boobs so like
I think you just kind of feel like the
world like sucks and
even if I leave I'm not gonna like get
away from this at least this like I see
like everyone's being like real like I
see it you're not bullshitting me you're
not hiding it I know you're a piece of
[ __ ] I don't have to like pretend
and they don't pretend they're just like
using you and that's it and
I don't know it's just like
crazy crazy experience for sure
um
before I started running away too there
was a time like in between
I it was my first experience with an
older guy I actually looked him up
recently I wrote like a post about him
um he he was born in like 71 I think or
no it was 60 66 or something
anyway he was a mover
so he came to my apartment complex he
was there two black guys came and I was
like oh my God like he's cute whatever
like dumb
he's like flirting with me gets my
number ends up coming and picking me up
like later that week my mom's never home
so I just like go with him
go to his house like have a sexual
experience first guy that I'd ever been
with that wasn't like circumcised so I
had no idea what was happening and then
um he like like this was before I ended
up running away and getting with James
so like he was the first man that like
started to groom me
and I think that also made me more
susceptible to the situation with James
because you're just looking for like
warmth or like acceptance and they know
how to give you that and also get what
they want with like without seeming like
they're hurting you
so he was actually
um like he played a huge role in that
and he was also the person that told my
mom where I was
which is weird
so like I think in between I would like
call him on a pay phone or like I had
like a little Nokia phone and I would
call him and be like hey like I miss you
this is happening and I would tell him
and he's the even though he was a
pedophile as well he's the one that told
my mom
where I was because I had told him
so he ended up like probably saving my
life from addiction or whatever else
um would have happened
but he also like I would go to his house
I remember one time I went to his house
and he had his friend Fame come over
this other guy he was huge he was like
six four
and there was like porn playing in the
living room you put on porn I was like
probably 13 at this time
um so I was kind of like confused like
what's going on and that was like the
first time that you guys ever like had
sex with me
I did not want to have sex with both of
them but I'm like alone in an apartment
in Detroit by myself
and it was just kind of like oh this is
happening this is fun we're gonna have
fun it's gonna be fine but I remember
like Fame was so like massive in size
not just like physically but you know
his penis was huge and I was very tiny
at the time
and it was extremely painful and
traumatizing
and after he just like left he was like
shook his hand and was like oh all right
later like and left and that was like it
and I just left on the couch like
what just happened
um
so yeah I uh I've been kind of like on
the fence about contacting him because
now I know like where he lives and his
number and everything because I remember
like little details now that I'm
starting to revisit
I'm sorry I'm jumping around
it's like how my brain is is working
right now I'm sure a lot of this you
block out too yeah it doesn't really
come up until I start like like piecing
it together and it's all very like
scattered
so I don't know how to like timeline it
out properly
um
and then he was also the reason he took
me to someone's house and we stayed the
night there and his moving company was
down the street on Grand River it was
like you could see downtown Detroit
moving companies on the left and there
was this laundromat with like a carousel
on the front on the right
so he was probably like six or seven
blocks down I woke up in the morning and
he was gone
so I like wake up and I'm in this house
with these people I don't know
and I'm like Hey where's Travis and they
were like oh we went down the streets
but to his you know office like if you
want to go down there's just a few
blocks you can walk
so I'm like okay I'm gonna walk because
I would like obviously know if there's
groups of men in an environment like
they're gonna have sex with you so like
I didn't want to do that so I left and I
like was wondering if maybe he left me
there because like he was trying to like
hook his friends up or something
so I like immediately get up and start
walking down the street and Grand River
in that area it's so vacant that like
all the buildings are empty there's no
like foot traffic there's no
I mean it's like it's like deserted
so I'm walking this car is like
falling behind me pretty like slow like
rolling behind me and I'm like very
aware I know he's there
he'd go up the street and then he'd
Circle back and like he has music look
really loud and so I could like I knew
it was him and then he would like Circle
the block again and then he would go
this way around the block and I was just
trying to like remember where he was
so I'm like walking on the street and
apparently this time he had went down
turned right and then came back up
because he cut me off like before I
could cross the street and he was like
trying to talk to me
and I was like Hey like what's up and he
was like get in the car and I was like
no like I'm going to my friends right
now like I can't they're waiting for me
and he like showed me a gun on his lap
and he said get in the car and I was
like okay
so I got in the car because there's
literally nobody like if I screamed and
as a white girl in the hood if you
scream it's not the same like it's not
going to No One's Gonna Do Anything
nobody gets involved with anybody
probably but I specifically felt like
with me
so I get in the car and we're driving
and he
he like was like looking for a spot but
like not saying much he was mumbling and
he had like his gun in his lap
and he was like you see all these fields
around us and all these buildings like
he's like you see nobody lives there
right and I was like yeah and he was
like
well if I like dump you right here like
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] about you
he's like you're just a stupid white
[ __ ] and nobody's gonna tell anybody
where you are like in so many words he
was just trying to get across like look
I could kill you and dump you in one of
these houses and like your family will
never find you
so you need to do what I tell you to do
and like you'll be okay
so he like pulls down the street pulls
up like alongside this like um like a
field it's like it's weird it's like a
neighborhood there's all these houses
but they're all empty and this vacant
lot was there so we pull up there and he
was like trying to get me to take my my
shorts off and I couldn't and I was like
I'm on my period I'm on my period like I
kept saying that like hoping that he
would just like not check because he was
like frazzled you could tell he was like
stressed out and and rushing
and he was like just like here just and
he pulls his like dick out and he was
like just give me head and put push grab
my hair and push my head into his lap
and I like had to give him head while I
was crying I was trying not to cry but
I'm like crying and he's like holding a
gun to my head while I'm doing it so
like
I I don't know how you get enjoyment out
of that situation at all
but he ended up like finishing
and I just like sat up and like didn't
look at him like the whole time I just
kept trying to like not look it look at
him because he didn't have a mask on and
I was like if I see his face or if I'm
like staring at him he's gonna think
that I'm gonna like tell on him
so I didn't look at him and he just like
ended up driving me back to Grand River
opened the door like told me to get out
and pulled away like nothing happened
so I like go into Travis's business I
end up walking there as fast as I
possibly can go into his office and I
try to get in the back and this girl her
name was Pam she was like the office
chick
she's like you can't go back there he's
busy and I'm like like knocking on the
door and she's like you can't go back
there I'm like visibly upset
and she ends up or he ends up coming to
the door opening the door and there's
like another girl back there with him so
like the whole time like this is
happening I'm just trying to get to him
and he's like with another girl in the
back
so I'm like devastated and I'm like
trying to tell him what's going on and
he's just like I'll be out in a minute
and shuts the door and just leaves me in
the lobby
so then I was just like I need to go
home like I ran across the street to the
laundromat because there's a pay phone
and I was hoping somebody would be there
that would give me change because I had
no money
and I didn't have change nobody would
talk to me
so this like Lincoln pulls up and
they're like hey this old man is like
hey come here and of course my
experience I'm like I don't want to come
to your car like I just want to go home
but like something told me like it was
okay like my gut wasn't telling me to
run away so I went over there and he was
like you don't belong here he's like you
need to like let me take you home
and I swear it was like
the first person like my whole
experience like in Detroit was the first
person that was like kind to me and
didn't want anything in exchange for it
like gave me 20 when I got out of his
car and he was like he needs to get home
like just go home like you don't belong
down here and he left and it was like
amazing and I don't know why after that
experience like I ended up running away
again like in my head like why did I do
that
and after like when my mom ended up
finding me
I don't know how she found me I'm like
getting out of someone's car this guy
that like
like had picked me up to like have sex
with him that he like ended up like that
was a crazy experience we had sex and
then he put me in the bathtub and peed
on me
so I'd never like had that happen I
didn't even know that it was going to
happen and it just ended up peeing like
all over me like my face my body and I
was so like disgusted
and then he took me home I didn't get to
shower
so he's driving me back to like the to
Brightmoor down this like side street
the house is over here
so he was going to pull up here and I
was gonna walk to the house
he pulls up and I see this blue Sunfire
like pulled on the side of the road and
the interior light is on and there's two
white people in the car
and I'm like
and I'm like oh my God is that my mom
and she like I get out of the car and
I'm like looking
and I'm like so afraid I'm gonna be in
trouble that like I almost don't want
her to see me because I'm so like
ashamed like I'm covered in urine
so she like sees me and she's like
Catherine get the [ __ ] in my car right
now
and I like get in her car and I'm like
crying and I didn't tell her what
happened like didn't tell her like for a
long time
she took me to White Castle got me some
chicken rings
and then took me to the police station
right down the street and I was
terrified to go to the police station
because it was literally right around
the corner from the house and I'm like
he's gonna see me he's gonna see me he's
gonna see you he's gonna like kill you
like you can't we can't be here so we
tell the cops and the cops told my mom
in front of me they were like you need
to just leave this alone like you need
to leave it alone you don't know who
you're dealing with like we're working
on it don't worry about it she's like
there's literally a house down the
street with with minors in it that he's
pimping out and you have somebody right
here that's telling you this is
happening why aren't you going over
there and like busting the door down
and they were like we can't do that like
it's a process like you don't know like
they just kept like excusing it and I
remember the female cop taking me out
back and giving me a cigarette
and I was just like I'm still not safe
like she's like she's giving like a 14
year old girl a cigarette and trying to
like reason with me and why I should
just let it go
like without my mom
which is like I don't think it's legal
to do that right like as a cop you can't
interview a minor or talk to a minor
without their parent
it was just mind-blowing to me there was
no moment like in that that
series of events where I felt like okay
I'm good like everything's gonna be fine
he knew where I lived so I was like
always afraid he was gonna find me again
um
but yeah that's like
it's a mishmash
how many years did this go on
not long actually it was like three or
four months
the sex trafficking part was three to
four months
of running away yeah so like how long
did you work as a sex worker prostitute
that's so fuzzy I honestly I because I
bled for a portion of it so like I was
like do [ __ ] count
and then I would like reason with myself
and I would be like
all these men I mean I slept with so
many men in that period
and I wasn't even 16 so I was kind of
like
[Music]
it didn't happen
I don't know how else to like describe
it my mom would like ask me and I would
be like nothing happened like
and I ended up telling her
I ended up telling her later
like as a grown-up
like after I moved out here actually
and she was like Catherine like what did
you think was gonna happen like when you
go to Detroit she's like you're a white
girl like you were dressing really
provocatively she's like you kind of put
a Target on your back
um
that's just kind of like hard to uh
process so I just kind of like
either it didn't happen or it did and
like it's my fault because like I
shouldn't have been there why did I run
away like I could have just stayed home
or like hung out with my friends
instead of like seeking that out like
why did I seek that out you know and
what do you think the
the core of it all was the lack of love
from your mom no daddy issues for sure
yeah I mean is isn't it always
yeah I told my dad my dad was extremely
racist so
I remember like staying with him for a
minute when I was like acting out my mom
I was like I hate you I want to live
with my dad so I went lived with him and
he'd beat his wife up all the time and
I'd call the cops cops would come and
she'd be like everything's fine and then
they would leave and he would never get
arrested
I hate saying this because like I love
I love my grandpa it's like weird he
like was my father figure and I I love
him and like he did change later
um but I do remember growing up like
they would say oh if you kiss like black
boys you'll get canker sores or like
they would say stuff that would like
try to like discourage that because like
it's super common in like down river for
like black guys to like get with white
chicks like it was pretty common but it
was also hated at the same time
and like there's still a divide like
River Rouge where I met my baby's dad
was still there's a white side and a
black side and people still like adhere
to it pretty much like the black people
live on one side white people live on
the other the projects are on the black
side
and it's just like is what it is like
everyone gets along but there's
definitely a split still
like I think even now
so I think just being wanting to be like
like fit in I don't know like white
dudes didn't like me very much in my
neighborhood because I was always kind
of like
I always had like bigger thighs and like
my hips were wider so they would always
be like oh like your hips are like they
would just make fun of my body shape so
I think like black guys were always like
Oh I like that I like that about your
body
so I would be like oh well I'm just
gonna go where I'm wanted so that's what
I did
and yeah I don't know my dad was
definitely very outwardly racist like
aggressively racist in public
he said he got beat up by a bunch of
black kids when he was a kid and that's
what made him hate black people because
he was a white boy who grew up in
Detroit
whatever
but yeah he kicked me out just goes on
for Generations he kicked me out because
I bought a shoestring CD it's like a
Detroit rapper
I bought a CD and he found it and he was
like you're not gonna have this music in
my house but he said like the n-word
and he like broke it and threw all my
[ __ ] on the lawn so I moved out
so yeah
so then I ended up getting pregnant by a
black guy
well do you know I'm 35. you're sorry
yeah so I was six but that was another
situation now like I was 16 and he was
24.
so my mom let him like come over and
stay the night she let him sleep in my
bed there were no rules I got pregnant
that's it I got married at 16 we moved
out when I was 17 and then I was like a
stay-at-home mom for eight years we
ended up having two kids he cheated on
me all the time
was like emotionally abusive
manipulative like all those things and
I'm still I'm dealing with that now like
just now before I was just like oh
that's just like my baby daddy like
that's my ex-husband we stayed married
for so long and like we didn't have a
terrible relationship all the time
which is I know it's so stupid to say
that but
I was 16. you know like I don't
understand why
every man even now while I just stopped
the cycle actually but my second my
second husband was 15 years older than
me
why like
is that Daddy issue thing is it like a
weird like
just crazy crazy to me I don't I don't
know
what are you doing with your life now
you're no longer a sex worker no well
I'm not physically
I did start only fans I did certain only
fans this year
you feel so bad saying that
um
I was like having a rough year
financially last year I killed it I made
so much money like more money than I've
ever made in my life worked for myself I
was able to be present for my kids 24 7.
like I have a three bedroom house like
it's nice I'm doing well like I feel
good how are you supporting yourself
with my business my clothing brand like
strictly that that's all I did last year
which is what you're wearing now yeah so
but this year was bad I think I like
ended up blocking myself
I had a third marriage
um actually we got married in June of
2020 and he left in March of last year
and he left
and never came back like there was never
a like he straight up like dipped out
and never talked about it
like it was
it was the most traumatic like
experience I think I've had in my adult
life
um he was super close to my kids great
step dad great husband and then one day
just like he was gone
so I dealt with that last year I just
like focused on my business but this
year I think I was like oh I'm good like
I'm Healed I'm fine
and it ended up sneaking up on me so I I
couldn't be creative like I felt very
blocked like I was like nobody's gonna
like what I put out so I can't put it
out and if I do I'm gonna get rejected
and that's gonna like devastate me
because I've dealt with so much
reduction
this past year so anyway June came and I
was like kind of like feeling better
about myself and I was like maybe I can
do this like
maybe it will help and I did and like
all of my stuff is like very like artsy
so it's like in a way a creative Outlet
it's not like just like a nude it's like
I like add music and I edit it and I
like make it like
expressive in like a sexual way but like
in my own way like I have complete
control over it I have control over who
gets to see it I can pick who I like
offer certain things to
and it's like helped me be able to stay
home with my family so
that's like the most important thing
helps pay the bills yeah I mean make
good money doing that so how does doing
only fans
how is doing how does it affect you
emotionally
I think positively I don't in a weird
way it's like boosted my confidence I'm
very like reserved and I I have a really
hard time making eye contact
um which is like puts people off or
makes them feel like I'm being dishonest
but like it's just like something that
I've learned that I can't
I can't look like men in the eye it's
very hard for me or if they yell at me
like I shut down like I turn into like a
six-year-old
like I just want to hide and like cover
my head and I don't think people like
understand that so
with only fans I'm not like talking to
anybody like with their voice there's no
eye contact there's messages
so if somebody says something like off
the wall or something I'm not
comfortable with or if they sound like a
dick pic and I'm like you didn't ask me
if you could send that please don't do
that you know I can like stand up for
myself
and it like it in a weird way gives me
like practice
that I'm now implementing in the real
world in like real world situations with
men
if that makes sense it's weird
but it's helped because they're like my
test I mean baby steps I guess yeah what
is the lesson to learn from what
happened to you when you were 14.
and 11. you know young teenager
why why did you why did you go there why
did that happen
I don't know I wish I like I wish I
could like have like a therapist and
figure it out but every time I've tried
therapy I just like I really just shut
down and cry the whole time and I don't
know if it's because people are prying
or asking like if I talk about it I have
to like be in a space to talk about it
you can't ask me a question and me
answer it like I have to be like in an
open I don't know how to explain it but
um
I have no idea I think
the biggest thing for me and the reason
why I wanted to talk about it is because
the media and like everybody's always
talking about sex trafficking and all
these like
scenarios that like
I'm sure they happen but it's not like
like the the entirety of the sex
trafficking like
thing is not going to be like you know a
kid in a Wayfair like container like
being shipped like it's just like so
ridiculous to me that that's like where
energy is being spent and it's not being
spent on like
the girls like me who were like super
lost and I I really can say that I I was
looking for something and I don't know
how to I don't even understand fully
like what it is
but I was always seeking I was always
like where can I find this feeling that
I'm looking for like this like warm
feeling my mom like worked all the time
and when she was home she would always
sit at the kitchen table and like write
in her notebook
and it was like Bill's stuff or she
would do crafts and I would be in the
living room on the couch by myself
and I'd ask her to come and stay with me
and she never would she just always had
something to do
so I think I just wanted
I just wanted somebody to want to be
around me
and like men always wanted to be around
me like it always they were always like
yeah but it's always
so like my relationships now are very
hard
because I'm always just like like what
do you want
like I always feel like nobody really
like
nobody really wants to get to know me
and when they do they're just like
they're just like oh wait like you're
[ __ ] up
or you're like too needy or you're too
like emotional or
like they just like get what they want
and then they're like oh I don't want
the rest
so it's kind of it's been hard to like
dating as like a 35 year old single
parent of four kids like
I mean you like say that and dudes like
run the [ __ ] away as fast as they can
but it's like I don't need I don't need
a man to like complete me but it would
be cool to like have
somebody that like is like I don't know
accepting
so it's affected me in that way for sure
um sexually it's hard I mean I had a kid
at 16 my body's like never been perfect
as an adult so I'm very like
self-conscious about my body
um so sex is hard I always like feel
shameful
um unless there's like a rare rare
partner like that makes me feel
comfortable which is not very common
um so I can never fully like let go
because I'm always
like what is this person thinking about
me like am I good enough do I look okay
am I like I'm very like worried about my
appearance all the time
because I feel like if I'm not like
looking good I don't have value like I
don't I don't offer anything
or maybe if I look good somebody will
think I'm cute and they'll want to get
to know me and then they'll be like
she's like cool too instead of just like
I know my kids like see it I mean I
don't bring anyone around my kids but I
don't want my daughters to grow up and
like repeat the same thing so I'm a
little scared about that what are you
doing to protect your daughters
um I'm like really hyper aware and very
um
I I like don't let them play on the
sidewalk in front of my house
you don't let them outside without me
um I live in Long Beach so it's kind of
like
understandable if you live in the city
like you kind of know there's always
like like somebody like tweaking walking
down the sidewalk you know I'm not gonna
let my kids play out there
um sleepovers like I'm super aware of
like who's there like I meet with
parents you know because I've had
situations at sleepovers where like I
used to sleep over at this girl Dion's
house all the time and her uncle her
uncle Michael would come up
from New Orleans and he would sneak in
the bedroom and like pull me out and
like we would have sex
and I was
probably 13 at that time too
um but he would have sex with me and the
other girl that would always stay there
her name was crystal
and he would like pull us out the same
night and like have sex with us he was
married with kids and
so I'm very like you were 13. yeah and
he was
in his 30s
yeah and then her mom found out
and we ended up finding out that he was
also sleeping with Dion who was his
niece like blood niece his sister's
daughter he was sleeping with her too
you've been sexualized since you were
forever forever yeah so
but also I'm like I did it to myself
like I I was dressing pretty
provocatively pretty young
so I don't know why I did that nobody in
my family did that so I don't know why I
made that decision because I'm sure if I
didn't dress that way like dudes
wouldn't even look twice
something happened to you as when you
were younger I don't know
I've like tried to go back because my
sister was I don't want to like share
her business my sister went through
something with my uncle
I lived with him so I don't know I don't
remember anything but I do remember
feeling like
weird in my bathing suit or like you
know I could be around anybody else in
my family and just be like you know
balls out like whatever like but with
him I always felt like different like a
little more guarded
and I I like vaguely remember one of my
aunt's husbands
he would like invite me to his apartment
all the time after they split up and it
would just be me and him there
and I remember like being in his room
and I remember him giving me a massage
I have not told anybody about that but I
do remember that you're old
I was I was young it was all like within
the span of like 12 to 14.
12 year olds need massage so probably 12
I would say but yeah we were alone and
he would just be like hey do you want to
come over like we can watch TV and like
I'm like dude nobody thought that was
weird
like him and my aunt are like split up
and like he's inviting me to his house
to like watch like nobody like red flag
that is there a lack of
of awareness of what was going on I
don't know what the hell was going on
with my family I'm just like
there's no way in hell my kids would be
alone with anybody even in my family a
male in my family like would never
happen
so I don't I don't know
I don't know
but definitely like
you're like oh well I have to like dress
like this
to get the attention that I'm seeking
for men right so that's how you get it
that's how you get your daddy daddy hole
filled
no pun intended and
I don't know it's [ __ ] up
okay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
um
I don't that's hard
foreign
it's hard because I don't want to say
like keep your guard up I don't want to
say like don't trust people like because
as I'm like learning and like figuring
this out and growing
I definitely I'm looking at life
differently like not everybody is going
to hurt me or before I would be like on
guard all the time like this person has
an ulterior motive like I'm always just
like ready
um but not everybody is like that and
that's cool but like my biggest thing is
like trust your gut like my gut in every
situation when I look back my gut was
telling me it was wrong
or like this isn't okay
and I just like ignored it or I would
like explain away the feeling and be
like no it's fine like they're nice or
whatever but it always ended up turning
out not good
so I was like okay it was I was right
like I just never listened to that
feeling inside
um that's important
and talk to you like talk to people in
your life maybe I mean I don't feel like
I was heard I tried talking to my mom
all the time
and I just didn't feel like she took me
seriously or she didn't believe me even
when I told her what happened in Detroit
it was if I tell her now like I told her
I was doing this and she's
she was like oh well what are you going
to talk about are you going to talk
about me you know like she's more
worried about like her
what she looks like as a mom
versus me because I remember when I was
running away we sat in this Myers like
Deli or they used to have like a little
cafe
and she looked at me and she was like
Catherine like if you're gonna keep
running away like I'm gonna take you
home you can get your stuff and you can
go and I won't tell anybody
because everybody in the family was
trying to find me and get me back but I
think she had reached a point where she
was like you know what just [ __ ] go
just go
she actually drove me home helped me get
my stuff took me to the bus stop and was
like you can go
and that's when I was like she really
doesn't care at all
because when she was looking for me when
she would find me I'd be like she does
love me it was like this weird like
validation that I needed from her and
then when she did that I was like I felt
so betrayed by her
and the Inkster police ended up picking
me up at a hotel with some dude that I
was like this was before like the pimp
situation with some dude I was like
hanging out with and his name was
Anthony
and he was probably 40.
and they broke in the hotel room and I
was there like naked
and I was like 13 I think at the time
and they grabbed me like wrapped me up
in a blanket grabbed me and took me to
the police station my mom came to get me
and I remember hearing the detective
because I told the detective I was like
my mom told me I could come
and that like was not good
because like I heard the detective
talking to my mom and he was like you're
wasting our [ __ ] time like you told
your your daughter your minor child that
she could go to a hotel with this man
that is in his 30s he also has this this
in this case like he was telling her all
the cases he had
and he's like you're gonna let your
daughter go and like be with him and
have sex with him and you know that and
you're okay with it
and like he was like like reaming her
and I felt so guilty because like I was
the reason that was happening I just
like tore up her whole life during that
period
I don't think she ever forgave me for
that
it's all like it's all your fault
I mean it was
I was running away like and none of it
would have happened if I would have
stayed home
I suspect there's something that made
you run away
yeah I don't I just what was it I had
like a nice house like
it wasn't a house it was an apartment
but like I had like a I had a boombox
at a TV like we had cute dogs like
I don't know why
I don't know
I don't know if I will ever know
but yeah I don't know teenage girls are
overlooked or over sexualized and I feel
like that's a huge issue I feel like
teenage girls that are like showing
their midriff or like shorts I mean in
school you're told like don't distract
boys don't distract teachers like why
are you wearing that how are teachers
supposed to do their job when you're
wearing that why is it why is a teacher
sexualizing me
it's summer like what do you I can't
wear like a tank top you know like it
was just so like that like cycle that
you're taught you know as a young girl
it affects you like your whole life
you're just like oh I can't do this or I
can't do that or I can't like walk alone
I can't wear a skirt you know like if I
do I'm wearing like crazy ass like Spanx
so nobody could ever take them off
it's like I'm always like premeditating
like where I'm going and like what to
wear and how to be safe and make sure
I'm not looking like I want a man to
like approach me
and teenage girls go through that like
their whole life and I think that's like
that's where it starts or like a dad
being absent that's where it starts
dad's like caused so much [ __ ]
when they like walk away like I just
don't think they understand like the
whole they leave
the percentage of the fathers have been
present in the interviews I've got on my
channel
I'd say it's like one percent yeah 100 I
don't think very many and if they are
present it was like a
bad experience yeah that's that's it
yeah because they're off they're off
curing cancer somewhere yep
so I think that's like a huge thing I
don't know
instead of like like assuming a young
girl like wants sexual attention or
she's a [ __ ] because she's like out
there like in the streets doing like
dumb [ __ ] like I was doing like maybe
pull her aside and like have a
conversation with her instead of like
making her feel shameful or or grounding
her or like negatively reacting like I
notice with my kids if they're like
throwing a tantrum or they're having a
meltdown like if I just grab them and
hug them like it diffuses it instead of
like shaming them instead of like going
like this like just like bring them in
you know like
love is the answer
it always is
very corny
all right Ken well thank you so much for
sharing your story oh yeah thank you for
having me help somebody hope it helps
you me too
you're still working on it ah
I think I will be for a very long time